[Music]
everyone my name is Luke Harrington I am
a senior JavaScript engineer at four
kitchens we're a digital agency and we
make big websites it's actually my work
on nbc.com and the apps that inspired
this talk the API work in the talk is
components as data a cross-platform
graph QL powered component API and if
that's not a mouthful we're gonna unpack
it don't worry I just threw a bunch of
buzzwords in there to get you all to
come all right so let's start with
components components are these things
that show up in our front ends and
everyone across our industry is using
them to build UIs they're the
fundamental building blocks of a UI
doesn't matter what framework what what
platform you're building on you're using
components to build it most likely so I
think components win we found a really
good abstraction for building UI but
what is a component so I like to define
components this way this is kind of like
pseudo math here a component is a
function of rendering props and state
and those words might sound familiar to
you if you've built a reactor let's
let's dig into those words a little bit
more so props I think of as read-only
external data there are basically the
parameters to your render function state
is going to be local data that changes
over time and your render is a
declarative representation of the UI
based upon the current props and state
so let's start with just this simple
example of a component and and then
we'll get on to the API stuff so here we
have a switch component this switch
component has a label it has some state
whether or not it's on or off
and it has some presentation to it you
know when it's on its green when it's
off so the thing about components is
that they're also composable so we could
take this switch component and we could
add it to a row for example and say we
take that row component and we add it to
our settings screen and suddenly we have
basically a screen in our application so
I love components as a 90's kid who grew
up building Legos I can't help but love
them they feel like Legos and they're
genuinely fun to work with and we see
this happening in our industry like
doesn't matter if you're building
something with Swift UI or flutter or
react react native view you're using
this general abstraction and I think
it's because it's a good one so I'm
gonna stop gushing about components now
because this is also an API talk and
you're thinking okay where do we get to
this whole graphic right so I just love
components so much I'm just gonna leave
this slide up for a second no let's move
on so when you get into building an
application there's these pieces to your
app to your architecture and I'm gonna
use this throughout the talk to kind of
describe this API approach so generally
you're gonna have some sort of database
or data store you're gonna have business
logic which describes the rules but your
business wants to accomplish and help
the user you're gonna have some data
fetching with some third party or
external API s and you're gonna DBD
normalizing your data from your database
with some maybe some third party or
other API data then you're probably
going to have some sort of feature
flagging a be testing
and then of course you're gonna have
some sort of component library and
you're gonna kind of stitch that all
together in a composable way into the
pieces and the pages or screens for your
application
so you can combine these things and
countless ways and it's actually it's
basically our job to figure out how do
we you know how do we put these together
and as you're building these things
usually there comes a point in the
conversation when you're architecting an
application of okay are we going to you
know take kind of like a more monolithic
approach or we're gonna to decouple and
build an API so when you're decoupling
we've had these kind of conversations
before who should use like a decoupled
architecture
what is decoupling let's define the
terms Winn should you do that in a
project lifecycle why why is it a good
idea why is it a bad idea in some times
and how how to but one that we generally
neglect and I don't think it's on
purpose but I think it's because it's
assumed is where where do we decouple
our applications so in this talk we're
gonna use our friend the decouple line
to kind of describe and explore this
question of where do you decouple your
application so as the decouple line
moves around your architecture some
really interesting features of your API
are exposed some the format of your API
is exposed and the content of your API
is different so let's start by
describing a typical decoupled
architecture this is one that I think is
basically assumed in general when we
build a pis for our apps and that is
that you basically decouple right before
business logic but right after the data
store and essentially you're building a
API that exposes the raw data of your
data store your data
and this API is going to have listing
functionality it's going to have
filtering functionality sorting
including or joining of some sort it's
pretty typical and a good example of
this approach is the JSON API spec which
is an API format specification in this
format you're going to roughly map crud
operations to HTTP verbs and the queries
are gonna look pretty atomic and
low-level and almost like a sequel query
where you're basically saying give me
the authors and you better know there's
an author's table somewhere in your
database and I want to get the posts for
those authors and there's probably a
post table and you can see what I mean
by kind of it being pretty closely
mapping to your data model so I think
this is what people usually mean when
they say that their API is restful and
let's be real no one really knows what
that means except for our fearless
leader Roy fielding but let's look back
here this this leaves if you look kind
of on the other side of the decouple
line this leaves a lot for API consumers
to implement its leaves them with
business logic further API fetching and
denormalization a be testing in the
whole gamut so let's move this line over
a bit to here so in this approach you're
exposing business logic in your API and
this is a really common approach for
product companies you're still exposing
the resources of your data store but
you're also exposing operations upon
that data this is it's more than just
resources or entities that you're
exposing a great example of something
like this is stripes API stripe is an a
payment as a service company and they
expose a really really powerful API
for working with things like charges and
and customers and subscriptions right
but you're not just simply going and
getting a subscriber and then deleting a
subscriber stripe also exposes parts of
their business logic in the API so you
could dispute a charge what a what a
HTTP verb does that map to not really
any and these these kind of api's can
get very powerful they they're
essentially exposing their business
logic to you and most of their customers
are going to be developers that need to
need someone else to deal with the hard
bits of payments for example so this
format and and the prior get really
powerful when you introduce something
like hey Dios hey do stands for Hyper
media as an engine of application state
another mouthful there so let me give
you a basic example of what hey Dios
looks like in action and this is a this
is a very basic example in my opinion I
think pagination of resources in your
API is an example of helium's so imagine
that we have this listing API where
we're going to get a list of things and
below our data we're going to return
this kind of like metadata attribute in
our response called links and the links
are going to include these things like
self next previous last first so if
these links exist the UI can know that
there's more to see or that there's
something else before this page of the
list so what they can do is wire up
their UI - based upon the existence of
one of these properties create a next
button or a previous button and in that
way the server is powering the state
we could do things like calculating the
last page by dividing the total count of
the number of items in this list by the
page size if some links don't exist then
you just simply don't create the UI for
that and the other really powerful thing
about habeas and hypermedia is that you
can swap out the implementation without
front-ends even knowing so in this
example I've switched to an offset based
pager you could do the same for a cursor
based pager and because the front ends
are basically grabbing this link and
running a get request on it they know no
different it's super powerful imagine
doing that for your users if you work on
a sass and you expose an API you're not
only exposing this really helpful
business logic but then on top of that
you're exposing all of these actions and
operations that they could basically
generate and machine read and work with
so there there's a kind of the
explanation for them for this
architecture so let's move the line all
the way over to this other side and this
one's a bit of a stretch I'll admit it
it's not really an API anymore you're
basically building a monolith where
you're sending HTML CSS JavaScript down
the wire but it's a decision to make
nonetheless when you're choosing your
application and I want to kind of
address the elephant in the room here
that the word monolith has become this
low-grade insult in our industry and I
think that's a shame I think it's a case
of guilt by efficient there's folks in
our industry that have been in the
industry for a long time and worked on
these large code bases or joined a team
as a new member and had this legacy
quote unquote application that was
really difficult to work with or maybe
it was poorly designed and it also
happened to be a monolith because that's
how everything was built for very long
time
but just because the different pieces of
the application don't communicate over
the network doesn't mean that the app is
poorly written in fact I would argue the
opposite you could take a poorly written
monolith and break it up into
microservices and now you have two
problems you have a poorly designed
application that communicates over the
network and you have cap theorem to deal
with now and consistency and concurrency
issues so don't go so hard on the
monolith I think it's a pretty good
pattern monolith does not mean spaghetti
code okay so let's move on to the next
this one's look interesting what is an
application that whose database is in
the client well it's an offline first
application or it's a local first
application and I'm really excited about
this this kind of pattern right here
these days in a world where people in
their data their private data has become
a product this pattern I think could be
really helpful okay I'll get off my
soapbox there's some really interesting
research happening in distributed local
first offline first applications it's a
hard problem so you have an app that has
been offline for two weeks and connects
to the network and needs to sync with
others with other nodes in the network
how do you solve that problem that's
it's a hard problem to solve but it's a
real problem if you have a customer
who's going to be out in the field for
two weeks or in low latency and no
internet connection this might be an API
that you consider building and it kind
of takes the form of syncing there's
some really interesting research
happening in this in this spot with CR
DTS which stand for communitive
replicated data types wherein you
essentially model the operations of on
your data as commutative so that you can
basically not worry about the order in
which operations happen when you can
reconnect to the network really excited
about this pattern and I think more apps
should be built with data privacy in
mind data ownership okay so finally
let's move to components as data in
components as data the backend is has
essentially absorbed a lot more work but
leaves something for the furnace to do
and at this point the backend kind of
becomes the front end in its own right
so what this looks like is an API that
serves JSON structured in terms of a UI
tree and if that sounds confusing we're
going to unpack it and get some examples
here so your components can be described
as data hence the name components is
data so let's get to an example here's
the most basic example I could think of
a hero component so here we have a JSON
blob with a field called component that
component field is going to map directly
to a component in your component library
and then you have the data and the data
is essentially going to represent the
props that are needed to render that
component any state that the component
might have is going to be locally
handled so I wanted to address another
thing when react was first released
there was this big conversation that
happened about separation of concerns in
the creators of reacts mind I think
there was this ability to question best
best practices and I'm glad they did it
but then also with the introduction of
hooks which is a way of abstracting
logic out of components and suspense
which is going to solve for data
fetching and a couple other problems I
think we've seen that the component as
an abstraction isn't necessarily the
best abstraction for expressing business
logic or data fetching so I think that
this pattern kind of works with that a
little bit so this is a scary part in
the talk where I need to load an iframe
oh my gosh it worked okay
whoo so we used this pattern to build
out nbc.com and all of its apps android
iOS Roku and the TV apps Samsung Vizio
so across platforms we've used this
components as data to basically render
these the slide show here some shelves
with your favorite shows this is us any
of this is us fans out there okay okay
all right
how about willing grace it's the 90s
yeah okay so we use this pattern at NBC
we started out kind of about right here
with a very data model centric API
exposing the raw data with very flexible
and powerful filtering sorting including
and joining kinds of of logic this left
a lot for the front ends to do and they
were all reimplemented basically the
same queries with basically the same
business logic and having to deal with
all sorts of denormalization on their
sides and a be tests they're all doing
similar a be tests and it just didn't
seem dry when ultimately we wanted a
consistent experience across platforms
so we moved the decouple line over a bit
and we included we kind of built this
proxy of sorts where we're including and
denormalizing data from multiple sources
multiple api s and giving the clients
much more to work with and much less
responsibility but then as we built this
out we found that what the business
wanted was a very powerful suite of a/b
testing and very quick cross-platform a
B testing and feature flagging and re
implementing that across platforms was
more work than it needed to be so what
we did was we move towards components as
data where we absorbed that work and we
absorbed the component library into the
backend
so some basic components that live in
the NBC data model would be you know a
slideshow that contains slides a shelf
that might contains a series tile or a
video tile so those are what we're gonna
be working with with our examples here
it's a it's a very basic example so we
chose graph QL to implement this pattern
and I think the reason we ultimately did
it was because of the types and the
queries the coupling of the queries and
the types and graph QL is a is a perfect
match in my opinion the way that these
types need to be shared especially in
the component library as as data it was
just really powerful to be able to
describe those with graph QL schema and
will show some benefits of doing that so
let's just do a quick overview of what
the graph QL schema looks like for an
application like this and this is again
a simplified example so we're gonna have
an interface called component with a
component field like we talked about
earlier in a treatment field and this
treatment field was essentially our
quasi like class name field that works
cross-platform
so if we wanted a component to be you
know the primary or the featured type of
component we didn't have to create a
whole new component for that we can kind
of just augment it with this treatment
field like a class and we have our video
tile and the video tile also has a
component and treatment field and it's
going to have a data field like we
talked about and that data field will
contain like an image title secondary
title and percent viewed we decoupled
the data from the component for reuse if
if another component type might need
video D so then we have our shelf and a
shelf is going to contain tiles so we
define a series tile in similar manner
and we union the video and series tile
together into this tile Union and the
Shelf data the data for the shelf is is
going to contain this items field
which is basically a slot for tiles to
live it's kind of like children but it's
more specifically kind of tied to a slot
of components so we're gonna introduce
this new interface called section right
and you'll see why in a bit but this
section interface is going to kind of
delineate the shelf shelf component from
other types of components it's a
component but it's also a section same
goes for featured slide shows is a
different type of components like a
featured component right and these
things might have different properties
different analytics information and
metadata information so introducing a
new interface makes sense so a slideshow
contains slides I think we get the
picture there and then finally we're
gonna have our page type the page type
stitches this altogether it takes a
featured field which is going to be you
know like that slideshow up at the top
on the home page as the example and then
the sections field which is gonna
essentially represent all of the shelves
in the UI and then our query well
obviously we'll take the naiton ID for
personalization and a platform so that
we can vary this on platform so let's
give another example this is what it's
going to look like in Apollo playground
so here we have our home page we're
using our page field we're querying the
home page for user ID loop on platform
web and you can see here that we're
spreading our slideshow fragment into
featured shelf into sections and as we
build out more and more components that
are of the sections interface we would
add more like a group or other types so
here we have our fragments that are
going to look as you would expect and
this is what it looks like to send back
a DUI tree as JSON
we have our page with our featured
section and our sections array and we
have our component called slideshow with
items of slides in sections are gonna
contain our shelf and in this case we
have a top picks for you shelf that
returns a bunch of series tiles
personalized just for you let's show
another example you don't have to just
build out pages this way there's nothing
that is forcing you to build out an
entire page response you could build out
certain features so when I talked about
absorbing the business logic this is
kind of what I meant one of the features
of NBC comm or really any media
streaming kind of platform is some sort
of continued watching feature where you
can pick up where you left off on the
videos that you've been watching so here
we've exposed a continue watching field
that just returns the continue watching
shelf a bunch of video tiles with some
percent viewed some images and the UI is
going to map over this field and
generically render its contents
so let's talk about this I think that
what we're describing here is some sort
of design schema where your component
libraries is described in terms of graph
QL in terms of a schema and this is I
think what we are trying to accomplish
often when we we build a design system
is we want rules we want structure and
this type system ensures that a great
example of this is when you throw in the
schema into an open-source tool like
graph QL Voyageur and you can see kind
of this component library described as a
graph so let's look at page which is
going to contain featured and sections
so go to sections where there's a shelf
data there's our tile union and then our
tile could be a video tile or a series
tile with their respective data
so what does it look like to actually
implement this on the front end we
showed kind of the back end
implementation and we're going to use
react to implement this so we'll start
with our component library that's how
most front-end projects begin and we'll
build out a slideshow a slideshow is
going to have some state as to which
slide it's currently on a slide number
and it's going to receive props and
remember that the props here are is the
data that comes from the API so it's
going to include this items field so we
can map over the items field and get
slides and we're going to generically
render the children using this
dictionary passing the data through and
the current state of the slide number
here's a slide boring slide component
these are just example snippets here so
these dictionaries are where kind of the
magic happens here these dictionaries
map to the interfaces and our schema so
you remember our featured interface in
our sections interface so we add the
respective components from our
components library library into these
dictionaries then when we want to go
render a component we use the respective
dictionary we grab the component field
lookup the component in the dictionary
and generically render it with its data
finally here's an example of how we
could stitch together that full page
query that way I showed you where we're
using the featured section with the
future dictionary grabbing out the
featured property and then rendering our
sections array and mapping over the
sections and rendering whatever
component we have so this is I think a
pretty interesting solution to a hard
problem that our that NBC hat
and maybe you have it too here are some
of the hard parts when business logic
gets fragmented and you're centralizing
the business logic you have to deal with
it in a centralized way and that can
mean bloat and something you tried to
dry out if you've ever tried to dry dry
out some code with don't repeat yourself
and then turned out oh actually I kind
of want to repeat myself you know that
pain the same goes for variants across
platforms
if iOS wants this slight tweak and
Android wants that slight a slight tweak
there can be variants in the design or
the components that get sent down or the
order of the sections right so handling
variants was an interesting problem that
we had to solve and we solved those by
creating this abstraction that we called
the conditional resolver and you saw
maybe if you're here in the last talk
what a resolver looks like and the
conditional resolver allows you to
essentially compose an array of
resolvers together with some basic
conditions that are going to be looking
at the args off of your query the
variables off your query and the context
as well and choosing a resolver to run
based upon the current context another
interesting problem was pagination and
lazy loading but we solved this by just
creating another component called lazy
shelf so we created a lazy shelf that
tells the front-end hey when you render
this thing there's not really much to do
but they in plet we're able to tell them
hey implement it like this when you get
a lazy shelf use this query that we're
gonna give you the query name in the in
the lazy shelf data and then use these
variables that we're passing to you and
when you render make this call and when
you get the call back in the response
you'll get a component and just swap it
out so if you get a lazy shelf you
render it it goes in fires off a request
and returns a shelf and then you just
swap in the shelf there's some good
parts too
this led to vastly simpler front-ends
it's a different problem set for them to
solve it's not easy
don't get me wrong but it's simpler
we're also able to centralize business
logic which happens a lot of pros less
fragmentation and differences across
platforms also centralizing a/b tests
and feature flagging has been a huge
boon being able to roll out an a/b test
across platforms with no front-end
changes is almost like magic same goes
for feature flagging and releases we
also get this design consistency with a
design schema the documentation of your
component library for a front-end is
described in the schema and you can use
all these really interesting graphical
tools out there to document it and
finally on the server side we were able
to do some query optimization and
caching that you just simply wouldn't
have been able to do on the front end so
here's what I'll leave you with I'm not
saying that everyone should use this
pattern in fact I would caution you
against it if if you have a very
transactional heavy app or if you have a
UI that is very forum based or I think
you get what I'm saying
if you're serving content or media and
you need to be very Swift and a/b tests
and you're doing that across platforms
this might be a good fit for you it's
not for everyone no and I guess what I'm
leaving you with is when you're going to
design an API think outside the box you
never know what you might come up with
and you can have some fun doing it as
well thanks everyone for having me it's
been an honor speaking here thank you to
the conference organizers and come talk
to me afterwards
[Applause]
[Music]